[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente y esto es lo que veremos hoy
miles de indígenas brasileños llegaron a
la capital para escuchar el fallo de la
corte suprema sobre la delimitación de
sus territorios ancestrales una decisión
histórica que sienta un precedente en
brasil como les explicamos en esta
emisión
y el horror provocado por la evacuación
de las tropas extranjeras en afganistán
le pasa factura en eeuu joe biden
mientras que algunos países de la región
como chile méxico y colombia se han
solidarizado y reciben a los afganos que
durante 20 años colaboraron con los
soldados de la unión americana y de los
aliados y vamos hasta california para
conocer un dispensario de cannabis que
se autodefine como un centro de salud
holística y que está entregando
productos de marihuana prácticamente
gratis a quienes demuestren que han
recibido una pauta completa de
vacunación contra el cob y 19
llevamos de inmediato a brasil para
nuestra historia principal miles de
indígenas abandonaron sus malocas esta
semana para dirigirse a brasilia e
instalaron un campamento a las afueras
de la corte suprema- mientras esperaban
una histórica decisión sobre la
delineación de sus tierras ancestrales
veamos más en el siguiente informe
el artículo 231 de la constitución de
1988 estipula que los indígenas son
reconocidos por su organización social
costumbres idiomas creencias y
tradiciones y sus derechos originarios
sobre las tierras que tradicionalmente
ocupan y le corresponde a la fiscalía
general de brasil de marcarlas
protegerlos y hacer respetar todos sus
bienes pero en 2009 tras una batalla
legal por un terreno en el estado de
roraima en el norte de brasil la corte
suprema- creó un marco temporal según el
cual los legítimos propietarios eran los
indígenas y no los campesinos que los
reclamaban ya que los nativos estaban
allí cuando se promulgó la constitución
en ese caso el fallo fue favorable pero
dejó abierta la puerta a reclamar la
propiedad de tierras que no ocupaban los
pueblos originarios en
1988 actualmente hay alrededor de 30
procesos estancados a la espera de la
decisión de la corte suprema- el más
emblemático es el del pueblo so klein
pues una interpretación literal del
fallo los relegó a un pequeño rincón de
sus tierras ancestrales
antes
nos mataban con armas lentamente y uno a
uno
ahora nos matan de un golpe con un
lapicero lentamente en inversión en
pagar y como al pueblo soplen el fallo
de la corte afecta a cientos de reclamos
de tierras muchos de los cuales ofrecen
un refugio a la amazonía contra la
deforestación en un país cuyo presidente
ya él bolsonaro ha dicho que muy pocos
indígenas viven en un terreno inmenso
bloqueando la expansión de la
agricultura los intereses poderosos
agrícolas tendrían un fundamento legal
más firme para desafiar los reclamos de
tierras indígenas que el congreso
tendría luz verde para escribir una
definición restrictiva de tierras
indígenas en la ley federal
y el presidente de nicaragua daniel
ortega continúa su cerco a la oposición
de cara a las elecciones de noviembre en
las que aspira a la reelección esta
semana la fiscalía abrió una
investigación contra el periodista
carlos chamorro crítico del gobierno por
el supuesto delito de lavado de dinero
la investigación hace parte del proceso
contra su hermana cristiana quien fue
arrestada en junio y luego de mostrar su
interés en ser candidata a la
presidencia en total alrededor de siete
precandidatos presidenciales y 30
opositores han sido arrestados
y el caos generado en el aeropuerto de
kabul en afganistán por la retirada de
las tropas y el miedo de los afganos y
los extranjeros a quedarse en el país
tras la toma del control por parte del
grupo talibán le ha generado críticas en
eeuu al presidente joe biden a su
administración ha defendido que la
misión fue cumplida la cual era proteger
a la unión americana de ataques
terroristas como el del 11 de septiembre
y no a afganistán varios demócratas el
partido al que pertenece vall d'en ya
anunciaron investigaciones para
determinar los fallos en la operación
mientras que algunos republicanos ven el
beneficio político en las elecciones al
senado de 2022 al calificar de
apresurado el retiro para coincidir
precisamente con el aniversario de los
ataques al world trade center al
pentágono y en pensilvania en 2001
entretanto algunos países de américa
latina se han solidarizado con los
afganos esta semana el gobierno mexicano
dio la bienvenida a cinco jóvenes
afganas integrantes de un galardonado
equipo de robótica veamos más en el
siguiente informe
por fin están en sus manos las visas
fueron entregadas por la secretaria de
asuntos exteriores de mexico
estas cinco jóvenes afganas fueron
acogidas por mexico hacen parte de un
equipo internacional de 20 ingenieros
aprendices de robótica decidieron salir
de afganistán después de que los
alemanes tomaran el poder con el pesar
de dejar sus estudios es un honor poder
estar aquí a salvo gracias por salvarnos
la vida al otro lado del planeta dos
días antes otra parte del grupo aterrizó
en doha qatar mismo curso mismas
esperanzas y la misma decisión con el
corazón en la garganta
le dejamos a nuestras familias
lo siento
es muy duro porque se quedaron ahí
porque nuestro país está destruyendo
néstor y conocidas como las soñadoras
afganas estas jóvenes entre las cuales
hay varias adolescentes ganaron un
premio internacional de ingeniería
robótica imaginaron un nuevo ventilador
para pacientes de covite hecho a partir
de piezas de automóviles viejos
y esta semana la administración federal
de alimentos y medicamentos la fda por
sus siglas en inglés aprobó
completamente el uso de la vacuna the
fighter iv by un tec contra el hobbit 19
el ente regulador estadounidense ya le
había dado el visto bueno para uso de
emergencia en mayores de 16 años el
presidente yo bailén dijo que esperaba
que aquellos que aún dudaban de los
fármacos acudieran a vacunarse ya que
esto significa que cuentan con los
estudios suficientes que prueban su
efectividad alrededor de 85 millones de
estadounidenses son aptos para vacunarse
pero aún no lo han hecho
y en california el dispensario de
cannabis de la pequeña localidad de
richmond que tiene alrededor de 100.000
habitantes lanzó una campaña para
incentivar la vacunación entre los
consumidores que consideran son
renuentes a vacunarse por desconfianza
en el gobierno y en las farmacéuticas y
están entregando diferentes productos a
base de marihuana a cambio de presentar
una pauta completa de vacunación incluso
han programado jornadas de inoculación
en el recinto y al finalizar le entregan
el cannabis a quienes se apliquen la
inyección les contamos más en el
siguiente informe
marihuana por vacunarse este dispensario
de cannabis de richmond california
entrega a sus productos prácticamente
gratis a quienes demuestren que están
inmunizados contra el jove y 19 días en
eibar y qinghai en water vaccination
para que cualquier persona puede venir
con su carnet de vacunación que pruebe
que tuvieron sus dosis de janssen o ya
sea de fai 0 moderna y luego pueden
aprovechar nuestro especial del día por
un centavo esos productos van rotando
así que pueden ser cualquier cosa desde
un gramo de cannabis hasta un paquete de
gomitas comestibles hasta una fritura de
cannabis etcétera
más de 1000 personas de esta pequeña
localidad ubicada en el este de la bahía
de san francisco han acudido a seven
stars a reclamar sus productos desde el
inicio de la campaña en junio
cigarrillos golosinas papas fritas con
cannabis chocolate y hasta vino de
cannabis todo esto por estar protegido
contra el coronavirus los
administradores del dispensario
consideran que los consumidores de
cannabis son reticentes a las
directrices del gobierno y a las
empresas farmacéuticas por lo que con su
programa ayudan a aumentar los niveles
de vacunación entre los consumidores
desde 2016 en el estado de california es
legal la posesión uso y cultivo con
fines recreativos del cannabis pero
desde 1996 la marihuana es legal para
uso medicinal sin embargo en eeuu las
leyes sobre su uso varían entre estado y
estado
su consumo recreativo es legal en 18 de
ellos y su uso médico en 36 pero
paradójicamente es un delito federal
el pasado sábado fue especial para la
cultura chacra de ecuador o los vaqueros
de los andes' la comunidad retomó una
tradición legendaria que no podía
celebrar hace más de un año a causa de
las restricciones para contener la
propagación del cob y 19 una competencia
de rodeo para defender sus tradiciones
nuestro corresponsal en quito- gustavo
ortega viajó hasta cuy invi para
llevarnos a conocer esta costumbre que
se niega a desaparecer
es el rodeo del ganado bravo un evento
que se produce una vez al año pero que
había sido suspendido a causa de la
pandemia
buscar hace parte de los vaqueros
andinos o chacras dedicados a la
ganadería desde la época de la colonia
que no están dispuestos a perder su
cultura
aquí aquí son un año que no mostraba
pero sí es un poquito triste que se haya
perdido estos eventos gracias a dios ya
con las vacunas todo eso ya empezamos a
otra vez reactivar poco a poco yo sé que
todavía toca seguimos cuidando pero creo
que aquí en el páramo el aire es limpio
todos estos eventos creo que no corremos
ningún peligro en mi pensar
entre los toros las barreras otra forma
de rodea mi canal de vuelta el rodeo
oscar defiende la tradición
empieza desde pequeño a cielo de los
corrales así empiezan a estar claro que
a veces nos explicamos pero allá en los
páramos de alguna cosa de esa guía más
de tres mil metros de altura donde
familia entrega esta herencia cultural a
su nieto uno de los nuevos rostros que
asumirán las riendas y la complica
tradición de nosotros jamás podemos
olvidar por el río por la lluvia el
sombrero y el poncho es la vestimenta
que cubra de frente mente que los
puestos
un nuevo llamado al ruedo que hace soñar
a este joven que ya busca dejar su
huella al pie de la montaña
concluye el rodeo y disfrutan de los
frutos de la tierra una forma de
mantener contacto con una serranía
indomable
y finalizamos hablando de la legendaria
agrupación de música rock nirvana porque
el hombre que apareció desnudo cuando
era un bebé en la portada del álbum
nevermind de 1991 presentó una demanda
contra la agrupación el hombre alega que
la imagen constituye un caso de
explotación sexual infantil spencer
elden alegó que había sufrido daños de
por vida por la imagen utilizada en la
portada del álbum sin embargo recreó
esta imagen como adulto en 2016 y tiene
tatuado en su pecho la palabra nevermind
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américas hoy natalia cabrera
pueden seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas en la
producción estuvo andrés doncel sigan
viendo más en france 24
[Música]